a still birth is a very sad outcome for
many families
but there is a new resource for
expectant parents to help monitor your
baby
bianca holman explains books
and influencers i wanted to know it all
to make sure i have a good pregnancy and
it is overwhelming whether you are a new
or experienced parent
the pregnancy journey while thrilling
can cause anyone to worry even with
proper prenatal care and routine visits
some families are still hit by
devastating news a stillbirth
a stillbirth is a death or a loss of a
baby at or after 20 weeks of pregnancy
or during delivery this affects about
one in 160 births
that's according to the cdc the court
could wrap around the baby's neck
there are lots of different things that
could happen you can lose the amniotic
fluid
and when these things happen the baby
slows down happy birthday a non-profit
is helping to educate expecting parents
about the importance of tracking a
baby's movement
especially during the third trimester of
pregnancy the campaign in the silver
state was made possible through a
partnership with the health plan of
nevada
the count the kids campaign is an app
for mothers to monitor their bundle of
joy
to know what's normal and note any
changes mother of two
marion falvey says she used the program
during both of her pregnancies
i would you know keep track of my babies
you know how he is alive how he's doing
and staying active
um because we had a little scare at the
time
where like he had arrhythmia if it took
you
10 minutes to get 10 kicks and then all
of a sudden it takes you
an hour or an hour and a half to get
those same 10
kicks then you want to be aware of that
so instead of tracking on a piece of
paper
the app makes it easy and convenient
access at your fingertips
and if there's a sudden change in either
direction you can tell your doctor
immediately trust your mom gut because
in the end it's
it's right if you can catch a problem
at that point you can save your baby's
life
bianca holman 8 news now the user
friendly app
is available on ios and google play
stores